[Musica]
sono il dirigente scolastico
dell'istituto comprensivo pirri 1 pirri
due e sono arrivato nel 2015 in questo
in questo istituto che si trova in
un'area di cagliari in un'area
periferica un'area che da storicamente
viene ricordata per essere un'area con
alcune forti problematiche sociali e
appena arrivato mi sono posto il
problema come affrontare questa realtà
questa realtà complessa e periferica la
domanda che ci siamo posti è stata molto
semplice se il lavoro che si stava
facendo era un lavoro efficace
era un lavoro che coinvolgeva i ragazzi
se dovrei dire una cosa molto semplice è
ugualmente cioè se i ragazzi all'interno
della scuola entravano motivati sentendo
di partecipare in maniera attiva
oppure meno se la scuola il lavoro che
si fa quotidianamente è un lavoro
percepito da tutta la comunità come un
lavoro che crea relazioni positive
relazioni forte e bene a queste domande
noi abbiamo dato sin da subito una
risposta negativa perché ci accorgevamo
che lungo questo percorso
io dirigo otto scuole che vanno dalla
scuola dell'infanzia alla scuola media
la scuola secondaria di primo grado
un percorso che va da i tre anni sino ai
13 14 anni
ebbene lungo questo percorso i ragazzi
progressivamente tendevano a perdere
quella motivazione che invece si ha
quando si entra e si fa una nuova
esperienza
e allora di fronte a questa idea che ci
siamo fatti sin da subito non positiva
della scuola
abbiamo coinvolto la comunità per
ricercare un nuovo modello un qualcosa
che potesse rispondere innanzitutto alle
sfide attuali che sono complesse perché
noi viviamo una società in continuo
cambiamento e la scuola deve essere
dentro questo cambiamento e ci deve
essere dentro con un ruolo attivo un
ruolo non di andare a rincorrere questi
cambiamenti in un ruolo partecipe e
protagonista
cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo coinvolto innanzitutto la
comunità coinvolgere la comunità è un
aspetto centrale non si può pensare di
fare un cambiamento senza rendere
protagonisti le persone che stanno
dentro questa scuola
se è vero che i ragazzi si sentivano
come dire in una condizione demotivante
il primo aspetto che siamo andati
proprio a vedere quali erano le cause di
questa demotivazione ed è un
atteggiamento passivo
e allora se volevamo cambiare questo
modo di fare scuola
dovevamo partire da noi stessi cioè
sentirci partecipi di un cambiamento ed
essere tutti quanti protagonisti di
questo cambiamento
la comunità scolastica il personale
scolastico
ma non solo il territorio gli studenti
le famiglie e le associazioni che vivono
dentro questo territorio
questo aspetto è stato il punto di
partenza per ripensare la nostra scuola
il secondo è stato quello di di
accettare una sfida e la sfida era
quella di riorganizzare complessivamente
in maniera sistemica
la scuola è una sfida è ancora in corso
ma ritenevamo che questo fosse un
percorso che doveva iniziare in maniera
completa dalla scuola dell'infanzia sino
alla scuola secondaria e allora abbiamo
siamo partiti ricercando un metodo
ricercando guardandoci anche intorno
quali altre esperienze si facevano in
italia e all'estero e siamo arrivati a
un modello che si chiama senza zaino
questo modello nato più di quindici anni
fa nelle scuole di lucca e che oggi
coinvolge circa 200 istituti in italia è
un modello che ha come dire messo
insieme tanti aspetti della tradizione
pedagogica italiana innanzitutto
montessori
ma non solo europea penso alle
tradizioni del nord europa del centro
europa tradizioni che oggi danno dei
risultati importanti nell'ambito della
scuola europea
questo modello nasce da un gesto molto
semplice la semplicità come una parola
che ricorre nei miei discorsi perché è
come dire un aspetto che deve
caratterizzare anche la stessa scuola
nasce da un gesto semplice e cioè la
mattina quando noi ci alziamo non
dobbiamo preparare lo zaino come fanno
praticamente tutte le famiglie tutti i
ragazzi e tutti i genitori
no perché i ragazzi arrivano a scuola e
dentro la scuola trovano tutto ciò che
gli serve per operare quindi lo zaino
non serve più serve magari portare le
poche cose che loro da scuola hanno
portato il giorno prima a casa
e un gesto importante perché anche
simbolico potremmo dire perché l'aspetto
della leggerezza in questo senso e non
del peso per andare a scuola è un
aspetto che caratterizza già i primi
momenti i primi gesti
ovviamente il senza zaino è un modello
che affonda le sue radici su valori un
aspetto fondamentale della scuola è
quello di trasmettere o meglio di
rendere partecipi una comunità ha dei
valori
noi abbiamo scelto il modello senza
danno perché porta l'attenzione su tre
valori che riteniamo assolutamente
indispensabili possedere in una società
complessa come la nostra l'autonomia la
responsabilità
il valore dell'accoglienza e
dell'ospitalità
il valore della comunità questi tre
aspetti di fatto dirigono tutto
l'operare quotidiano della scuola dei
docenti degli studenti percorso di
autonomia cosa significa costruire
dentro una scuola percorsi di autonomia
e di responsabilità per i ragazzi allora
il primo punto che sicuramente è quello
di avere chiamiamolo così un
prerequisito costruire un clima di
fiducia essere costruire percorsi di
autonomia per i ragazzi quindi citando
montessori far da se accompagnati da
delle guide che sono i nostri docenti ma
anche i nostri genitori perché anche
loro hanno un ruolo dentro questo
percorso è innanzitutto creare un clima
di fiducia un clima di fiducia reciproco
tra docenti e studenti
il secondo è quello che gli alunni si
devono sentire partecipi delle scelte
anche delle più piccole e questo è
l'altro aspetto che caratterizza la vita
il vivere quotidiano di queste scuole la
responsabilità sta trento queste scelte
le scelte quando i ragazzi sono chiamati
in maniera attiva a fare delle scelte e
sono chiamati innanzitutto a prendersi
delle responsabilità ospitalità e
accoglienza ospitalità perché le scuole
devono essere luoghi dove si crea
benessere
e allora se si deve creare benessere
dove li stiamo bene l'elemento
dell'ospitalità è all'origine di questo
percorso
ospitali innanzitutto curando i luoghi
gli spazi organizzandoli dandogli un
senso una funzione luoghi dove si lavora
e si lavora in maniera cooperativa
individuale dove una comunità insieme si
incontra e cresce accoglienza perché
dentro l'ospitalità e questa modalità di
rapportarsi c'è un altro valore
importante della vita attuale accogliere
accogliere le diversità accogliere le
esperienze di stili le modalità di
rapportarsi alla vita e che spesso sono
differenti ma che nell'incontro possono
trovare il modo più vitale per
esprimersi la l'aspetto dell'accoglienza
poi lo leghiamo anche all aspetto della
relazione perché l'esperienza scolastica
deve e risottolineo questa parola deve
deve trovare nella relazione quotidiana
nell'esperienza quotidiana quella quella
quel motore che poi porta ad una
formazione ad una crescita individuale e
che significativa cioè e fa parte
diventa nostro patrimonio patrimonio di
una persona e di una comunità comunità
una scuola che non lavora per creare una
comunità
innanzitutto professionale cioè una
modalità di lavoro in team in squadra da
parte dei docenti del personale
amministrativo e via dicendo è una
scuola che non lavora bene l'aspetto
della comunità di pratica noi la
chiamiamo così cioè di condividere
percorsi di studiare nuovi percorsi di
ricercare di affrontare le situazioni
non individualmente ma insieme
collettivamente un problema diventa un
problema non di una persona non del
singolo ma dell'intera comunità questo è
l'altro principio che noi come dire
cerchiamo di percorrere e di realizzare
il metodo viene chiamato approccio
globale al curricolo anche qui c'è un
cambiamento molto importante nel senso
che il curriculum viene inteso
sostanzialmente in quello che i docenti
progettano programmano un tempo si
chiamava il programma oggi
noi guardiamo innanzitutto a l'ambiente
di apprendimento all'organizzazione
dell'ambiente di apprendimento e
nell'organizzazione dell'ambiente
dell'apprendimento visto non soltanto in
termini di organizzazione della lezione
ma ha visto globalmente in termini di
organizzazione dello spazio delle
relazioni delle scelte formative delle
relazioni e dei team da creare tutto
questo crea un approccio un approccio
nuovo dove un ruolo molto importante e
deve essere quello con le famiglie con
le famiglie e quindi per ricercare
insieme a loro quegli strumenti più
validi per avere un percorso che va
dalla scuola alla famiglia e della
famiglia alla scuola
arriviamo alle ultime cose quali sono
poi concretamente ciò che noi facciamo
valorizziamo la l'attività cooperativa e
questo lo facciamo partendo proprio dall
organizzazione dell'aula dal setting
cioè non ci sono più
banchi cattedre
ma ci sono degli strumenti degli arredi
innanzitutto che consentono e
favoriscano il lavoro cooperativo non
solo non è pensabile nel 2018 che ha una
stessa ora tanti ragazzi facciano la
stessa cosa
lo abbiamo detto valorizzare le
diversità significa valorizzare più
percorsi e allora ecco un altro degli
aspetti importanti che la
differenziazione dell'insegnamento
dentro le nostre aule si fanno spesso
attività differenti
contemporaneamente i ragazzi secondo i
tavoli svolgono attività differenti
altro aspetto importante è che noi non
pensiamo all'innovazione soltanto in
termini di tecnologia innovazione è un
mix che cerca di come dire mettere
insieme tradizione e innovazione cambia
me in tecnologia e magari l'uso delle
mani che spesso si stanno oggi perdendo
in questo mix consiste la capacità di
rendere i ragazzi si attenti alle
innovazioni ai cambiamenti ai nuovi
strumenti ma non solo
attenti anche a non perdere certe
competenze che sono assolutamente
indispensabili nella propria vita per un
percorso di autonomia e di
responsabilità
io voglio finire citando una un lavoro
che ha fatto una ragazza pochi giorni fa
nella scuola che ad una richiesta da
parte dell'insegnante di scrivere un
testo che raccontasse la sua esperienza
dentro l'istituto comprensivo di pirri 1
per i due
ebbene questa ragazza ha detto che la
sua esperienza la si può riassumere come
una parola e la parola è libertà
non non veniamo a scuola con il
materiale che serve uno zainetto leggero
ci accompagna non ci sono le classi ma
le aule che i profili con i professori e
noi ci muoviamo da un'aula ad un'altra
sulla base delle discipline che andiamo
a fare e c'è sempre il tempo per un
sorriso uno sguardo una parola tra di
noi
io credo che in queste parole dette da
questa ragazza ci sia l'idea profonda
dei valori della scuola l'idea profonda
dei valori che accompagnano questa
esperienza che si chiama senza zaino
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]